in 2015 we took down oryx on his throne
world and now finally it's time to go up
against his sister the hive trickster
savathun in destiny 2 the witch queen
the new expansion has all the awesome
destiny action you've come to expect but
there's so much more in this edition to
explore on top of paying off a ton of
story threads and mysteries we've been
waiting years for bungie's also laying
plenty of new groundwork with the most
expansive campaign that destiny has ever
had a supernatural new location that has
much more going on than it seems
and for the first time enemies that can
use the light against us
oh and we're also getting one of these
the witch queen is one of bungie's most
ambitious story campaigns ever and its
roots go all the way back to the first
destiny we initially learned about the
witch queen of the hive sabathune in the
2015 expansion the taken king when we
fought and killed her brother oryx in
the king's fall raid unlike her brother
though the cosmic con artist savithun
has as much brains as she has brawn and
since we killed oryx she's had her
fingers in just about everything that's
gone on remember destiny 2 forsaken that
was all savithun all those hive that we
fought on titan in the first three years
of destiny 2 sabathunes that whole thing
with the giant rogue cabal baby and the
crown of sorrows raid sabathune you get
the idea but now in the witch queen it's
time for a straight up fight the
upcoming battle will feel very different
for veteran guardians because it takes
place on savithine's throne world a
spiritual realm that the wily witch
queen is filled with all sorts of new
puzzles and traps the witch queen
campaign is more cerebral than past
expansions and doesn't hold your hand
the way past destiny campaigns have you
really need to use your brain to get
through it because it's a fight worthy
of the legendary trickster she's gonna
do everything she can to get inside your
head what is your truth now
it's got all the shooting and blowing
stuff up that you could want of course
but even that has been updated and feels
new that's thanks to savithun's greatest
trick of all giving her hive the power
of the light that's right hive guardians
baby if you thought titan shields and
crucible were rough wait till a hive
knight uses two of them on you these
guys are much more than a new wrinkle in
destiny's already stellar combat these
lucent hive are a literal game changer
and hey now you finally have the chance
to kill a ghost if you're into that sort
of thing but you probably are you freak
fortunately you have some new toys of
your own to help you fight back the
witch queen comes with a ton of new guns
and the centerpiece is the glaive this
thing is a sword shield and gun all in
one what more could you want maybe the
ability to customize and make it your
own you can do that too thanks to
destiny 2's new weapon crafting system
combine that with the totally revamped
void subclasses and we've almost got a
whole new ball game here finally yet
another way bungie is changing things up
with the witch queen is the campaign's
legendary mode that's right bungie is
bringing back legendary difficulty it's
in that insanely tough but you know you
can do it sweet spot that you like so
much and the challenge seamlessly scales
when you play with fellow guardians so
it's just like old times when you
struggled through other bungee games in
legendary mode with your friends except
now you're old and your back hurts and
you like loot right well playing on
legendary gets you more loot better loot
and if you manage to make it all the way
through the witch queen story you'll get
plenty of rewards that'll let you show
off your destiny cred so you get the
satisfaction and the goods but the
campaign is just the start of what
bungie has cooking in destiny 2 this
year the new expansion also brings us
season of the risen which kicks off a
new year of destiny's intensely dramatic
week to week story looks like we're
going to be spending a lot of time with
the gabal empress kaitol because she's
got light suppressing tech she can wield
against these new hive guardians you
want us to hit them just don't use that
stuff on us thanks and let's not forget
which queen is also giving us a new raid
on march 5th just a couple of weeks
after launch not that we could forget
we've got it marked on our calendar the
witch queen and season of the risen
marked the start of the busiest year
ever for destiny and judging by how hard
bungie is mixing things up right now i'm
not sure anyone can guess what they've
got in store for us this year but our
bodies are ready just don't say
i didn't warn you